what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so getting into Justice League
justice lost this is the prelude to no
justice so a lot of justices in there
but this is the pre loo to know justice
and this is really like the last story
of the Justice League as we know it
before Scott Snyder and company change
everything up now one of the things that
I had talked about in the last video
that we did that People vs the Justice
League we are talking about Christopher
pre-strung and the idea of Christopher
priest writing is to take characters and
make them a lot more tangible and
relatable and really draw a lot of
politics into it now that's not
necessarily a bad thing it really kind
of depends on how you do it and the way
he does it here in the Justice League is
actually amazing because it takes this
team and it kind of throws them into a
situation that we're not normally used
to initially this picks up really with
like the aftermath of the people versus
the Justice League which has really kind
of changed the way the public sees them
in the sense that work the Justice
League has historically been this sort
of superhero team that's above reproach
in the realm of DC Comics nowadays
people look at it much like they would
look at any kind of city police or State
Police or like a federal organization
and they kind of question it and this
really comes initially with like this
this congressional inquiry at the House
of Representatives where you have cyborg
who's currently the leader of the
Justice League who's brought before this
committee and is basically you know can
you prove to us that the Batman who shot
neo senator Haas grofe was not actually
Batman can you prove that conclusively
and for the most part the response of
cyborg is I cannot prove it conclusively
because I won't tell you who Batman is
because I don't know who Batman is and
it's kind of interesting because it's
like kind of feeding into this idea that
the general society doesn't really know
anything about the Justice League and
it's kind of intriguing because while
all this is happening you actually have
Martian Manhunter who's watching the
events unfold while he's currently in a
different form now this is the part that
goes into no justice in this sense that
Martian Manhunter is kind of rallying
Simon Baz and Jessica Cruz for a
particular cause which leads into them
basically leaving and going off on this
campaign but what you have is you also
have a lawyer who's basically they're
keeping an eye on everything you know a
lawyer Regina basically who's kind of
monitoring everything and she's the
attorney for the Justice League but the
idea here is that she's not really who
she claims to be and we'll find out here
in a second but what is up happening is
as Justice League responds to a train
incident that happens in Estes Park
Colorado what you end up having is this
train that kind of derails in the middle
of town and because of how it derails
and because of the various chemicals
that it's that is
carrying if they start blowing in a
different direction which they're
actually blowing north at the moment
that combined with the fact that it's
snowing basically meaning combined with
water could very well just start killing
everybody in the immediate vicinity and
so the response of the Justice League
and Batman's Justice League of America
is tend to the north and then focus on
everybody in the West and keep
everything under control the problem
with this is that it's a matter of
public perception it doesn't really
matter what's true what matters is what
people think is true and so what people
see when they look at the circumstance
is the north side of Estes Park is where
all the rich people live and everybody
else lives everywhere else and so the
perception is that the Justice League
are racing to save the north side of
Estes Park because that's where all the
rich people art and so the perception
gives off that ideology which people in
turn believe here and so we're Regina
you know as a Justice League lawyer is
taken to the watchtower where
everybody's supposed to meet but then
cyborgs watching all the events unfold
and Estus and chooses to respond this in
turn leads to Regina kind of revealing
the fact that she's not actually who she
claims to be now of course this also
coincides with the idea that you had
Aquaman who is basically recovering in a
part of the the watchtower Regina didn't
know about it Aquaman shows up and
Regina turns out to be one of the
extremist fans who believes that she can
fix the Justice League and so she's
basically screwing everything up now of
course Aquaman defeats her but with
regards to Estes Park in regards to
everything that's going on there it's an
interesting situation because this is
one of those scenarios where again
people's perspective of the Justice
League is changing but the argument
that's kind of being made here is that
where cyborg is taking more of a
political approach and he's trying to
save all sides it's a situation where
you please everyone and no one at the
same time the nature of the Justice
League is to say we don't really care
how you see us this is the job that we
do and so where you kind of have people
going back and forth and is this sort of
debate that's going on among the Justice
League of course they basically end up
saying look like we've done what we need
to do there are rescue forces here like
there are ambulances and there's police
there's no reason for us to be here
anymore
and where cyborg wants to stay the idea
is all you're doing is putting on a dog
and pony show you're here for the
cameras you're here for the press and
you're here to maintain good publicity
let's get out of here and actually do
our job and so that's where people ended
up you know end up kind of bailing out
Batman grabs his Justice League of
America and leaves well from there
that's when you start to switch into
like this whole huge ramifications
whenever there is a situation where
people can take advantage of a situation
then they will and so what you have here
is opportunism you basically have one of
these like shoddy lawyers who's on TV
and he's kinda like hey have you not
been saved by the Justice League when
you feel like you should have well then
call me and like you're entitled to
money and so you have like thousands of
people who have signed on to a
class-action lawsuit to sue the Justice
League because they haven't rescued them
in particular points in time now again a
lot of that's personal entitlement right
like a lot of people are like I deserve
to have been saved in that situation you
know the Justice League should have
saved me now all that really kind of
feeds into the idea that a lot of people
are think they're more important than
they really are and that's kind of the
the the idea that's that's really being
presented is it's the Justice League
can't save everyone and so what happens
when like people who weren't saved or
people who lost their homes or something
like that what happens when they in turn
turn their guns against the Justice
League like what is up happening in that
situation at the same time because of
the fact that the watchtower had been
sabotaged by Regina the place is
basically kind of go into pieces and
literally like crashing down to earth
and so it really takes some fast
thinking from cyborg combined with the
efforts of killer frost to basically
save the whole place in the sense that
they push it faster down into the
atmosphere and then killer frost
basically uses her power to keep it from
burning up and it basically ends up
crash landing in the kingdom of Red Lion
now in the kingdom of Red Lion Inn in DC
Comics is kind of crazy because red line
himself Matthew bland is very much black
panther I mean he was designed to be
that way and I'm pretty sure Christopher
priest has done interviews where he said
that's definitely the case the
difference between Matthew bland and and
black panther is that T'Challa in Marvel
Comics is King by really by rightful
rule in the sense that it follows a
monarchy and he basically went through
all the trials and tribulations in order
to become a king Matthew bland is your
stereotypical warlord in the same
fashion as like Paul Pott in the Khmer
Rouge in Cambodia he's a guy that
basically rose to power and said like
I'm annexing things and I will eliminate
anybody who gets in my way it doesn't
matter who they are doesn't matter what
age they are the guy is cold-blooded and
so what you end up having is basically
this massive Justice League Watchtower
which crash-lands in Africa and then you
have all these rebels who descend on it
well you can imagine how this looks in
the public eye people who are not there
and don't know anything about the
circumstance will still chime in because
for whatever reason beyond human
understanding they think they know what
they're talking about and so the entire
public perception of everything that's
going on here is the Justice League hate
people in Africa that's the perception
that's being given to the general
public again like these are people on on
social media on Facebook on Twitter you
know on YouTube who have no clue what's
going on but they believe they know
what's going on and for them that's the
only thing that matters literally the
Justice League's in are in like a rock
and a hard place because what you end up
having to sort of to sort of top all
this off is you end up having like all
these different these different like
rebel forces who literally start
launching attacks in an effort to get
inside of the watchtower at the same
time all that's happening you also end
up having the fan from the previous
story arc who shows up to fight Batman
now this is really kind of Christopher
priests wrapping up some plot threads
with regards to the fan and the whole
concept behind it and the reason why is
because with a fan of again you know
with the last video with it having been
established that the fan is basically
one of the people who worked on the
watchtower and has since kind of become
more of an extremist he basically faces
off against Batman he subdue pretty fast
if it's wrapped up pretty quickly that's
something that I want you to keep in
mind because Batman doesn't kill him
instead what we end up doing is
basically picking up with the Justice
League of course cyborg defeated by Red
Lion but we pick up with the Justice
League that on one side is trying to
protect technology that really is quite
dangerous if put into the wrong hands
that there's alien technology in there
there's all kinds of weapons in there
that if it fell into the hands of a
dictator or someone like Red Lion they
could use it to not only invade like the
immediate territories but launch some
pretty significant Wars and inflict an
insane amount of damage and so the
response of the league is we can't let
that happen
but again public perception is how all
this comes down not only that we're one
of the rebels kind of loses it and fires
off a shot a Superman in turn he
actually ends up hitting Wonder Woman so
was things just getting like from from
bad to worse to worse to worse they've
literally walked into a war zone
but from here like it's a matter of
getting Wonder Woman out of there now
the problem with Wonder Woman and this
is one of the weird situations when it
comes to her character is Wonder Woman's
been depicted as bulletproof and she's
been depicted as not bulletproof and
this instance she's not bulletproof
it really kind of depends on on who's
telling the story and how it is they
wanted to unfold
Superman's initial response is to grab
her and leave but the flash steps in and
says no no no no let me take her this
entire region is is is a powder keg I
mean they're like if you leave then like
there'll be no one here like cyborgs
gone you're here but like there's maybe
one or two other people and that's it
but no one's here on the same level of
power as you they're basically afraid of
you which is why they haven't invaded
yet because you could just destroy them
all and almost
give an eye but if you leave then it's
open season and so Superman ends up
staying behind but what we end up doing
here is basically picking up with cyborg
who essentially wakes up in the chambers
of Deathstroke himself now for death
jokes part the reason why he's here is
because he's a gun for hire Deathstroke
has no allegiance to anybody
Deathstroke's loyal to the paycheck but
where he's loyal to Matthew bland at the
same time he does kind of have his own
moral compass in his own perspectives
and what he is up doing is just kind of
leaving you know cyborgs here with the
ability to escape you know leaving a
knife and in that kind of a thing but
again back at the Justice League
Watchtower it really is a war zone and
that's that's the crazy thing is you've
got rebels firing and firing on rebels
you've got like citizens who are kind of
caught up in the crosshairs everything
that's really kind of exploding and
where Batman basically shows up with the
fan and Aquaman to attend to cyborg this
is when things get kind of hairy and
this is where things get kind of screwed
up because what you have is you have red
line who basically says look your
Justice League is caught up in this
massive political event and if there's
any one thing that America hates it's
looking bad in the public eye so either
we can continue down this trend and I
can let the world continue to believe
that you guys really are that screwed up
or you guys can give in to my ransom
demands you guys can basically give me
like a huge sum of money
well then return to this cyborg cuts off
red line basically defeats him quite
readily and then Batman and Aquaman
respond to the entire crisis that's
going on well the funny thing about this
is that while all this is happening red
line and Deathstroke basically show up
with a fan and Deathstroke takes the fan
out and this is why I love Deathstroke
so much this is one of the reasons why
Deathstroke is so cool because as soon
as he gets in there you know he's as
soon as the Justice League turned their
attention to him he's basically like
stepping into a war zone like this you
know it's some war-torn African
territory this is new to you but to me
and people like me this is everyday life
you guys do not have this stomach to
basically deal with a situation like
this and that's what's so interesting
and that's really the big criticism that
Christopher priests kind of gives here
with regards to the Justice League that
the Justice League serves the purpose of
like protecting the world but more often
than not that threats the Justice League
respond to our threats based out of
America and that's why the nickname for
the Justice League in these various
war-torn territories is to just us leak
like it's just us you know you're not
allowed to be a part of this league like
that's the perception people give off
because you never really see the Justice
League in a territory like this and
where you as the Justice League has say
to have saved the world from monsters
and you save the world from alien
threats what you haven't done is save
the world from its
and you can't it gets it really kind of
gets cool when it comes down to the
nature of the league now this of course
results in Deathstroke temporarily
facing off against the Justice League
but not that often one no one basically
responds and of course Wonder Woman ends
up taking out and you know taking out
Deathstroke but that's kind of the big
revelation that's given here it's like
this whole idea of the rebels and and
these factions and things like that this
is all put forward by red line red lines
set all this up this massive war-torn
territory and it's almost impossible to
decipher in break apart the various
pieces and make it all make sense and so
the response of cyborg is Deathstroke's
basically right and we can't police
people that's not the role that we play
and so the coolest point here is a
cyborg says that's probably the most
difficult thing for the Justice League
to have to accept is that we are going
to have to look around and we're gonna
have to see these war-torn territories
we're gonna have to see how screwed up
everything is and just leave it that way
because they're gonna have to solve
their own problems and so from here like
you pick up this cyborg and Batman after
the whole crisis is averted and after
everything is done and one of the
questions that cyborg has here is like
is the death of the fan at the hands of
Deathstroke where Batman has a no kill
rule in the sense that he does not bring
anybody physical harm like that and
neither does the Justice League
cyborg looks at the situations and says
I can't help but think that the world's
greatest detective would bring the fan
basically this is this person that knew
so much information about the Justice
League a person that had to be taken
care of that Batman would bring him to
this war-torn territory knowing
something like this what happened and
that's the question of cyborg did you
bring that fan there so he would be
taken out so he would be killed and
we're about me I kind of denies it and
says no that's not exactly what I was
shooting for if he was it's not the
worst idea it's pretty smart I mean that
or half Superman like you know throw
them into the Sun or something like that
just fly him into deep space and leave
him there but it's not it's not the
worst thing but again this segues
directly into the events of no justice
because what you end up having is
Martian Manhunter who basically shows up
to the Justice League and the Justice
League of America and somebody says you
guys need to come with me and of course
we've covered the first issue of Justice
League no justice so feel free to check
that out so you can get an idea of
what's going on but with that being said
guys we're gonna go ahead and ring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys to
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
peace
[Music]
you